and brother can you uh like uh I've seen
many videos on this like the purpose of
life yes and um people say that God made
humans just for you know to praise him
and to glorify him and um you know that
those people that say that those people
that say that they're very ignorant if
you're
designed to be filled with love and
joy by entering the presence of God and
you enter the presence of God by
praising him and when you do that that's
when you experience true love true love
true peace true Joy that's beyond
description where's the
problem yes brother because in your
prayers you say that we don't need God
uh uh God doesn't need us we need God
but I answer the question you didn't
hear me see you didn't hear the answer
God doesn't need you but he designed you
to find true happiness and love and joy
in his presence and you don't enter his
presence by disobeying him defying him
rebelling against him you enter his
presence by obeying him and delighting
to be in his presence so he doesn't need
you so he created you for the purpose of
experiencing this perfect love that the
father Son and Holy Spirit experienc but
you can't experience it if you rebel
against him if you don't want
it yes so that is the ultimate purpose
of human life and that gives meaning
well think about it I want you to think
about what I just said if I was
created to find true love and joy and
peace that surpasses all understanding
in the presence of
God yeah and the way I enter that
presence is not by disobeying him
rebelling against him doing what I want
but entering his presence by obeying
him then how can I find the true meaning
of life and true satisfaction by turning
away from him when I was created to find
true happiness in him in his
presence right right right yes brother
go to Psalm
yeah Psalm
1611 thou will uh show me the path of of
life in thy presence is fullness of joy
in whose
pres uh in God's presence is fullness of
joy okay and then what
else at thy right hand there are
Pleasures forever more so wait it's in
his face that you'll experience fullness
of joy it is in his right hand there are
Pleasures forever more so you have to be
in his hand in his face to experience
the fullness of joy and everlasting
Pleasures how do you enter his presence
through Disobedience and rebelling doing
what you
want no so then what where is the
objection saying oh so God doesn't need
me but he demands that I worship Him in
order to be happy yeah because if you
don't want God then God is going to give
you what you want well you don't want me
all right then I hand you over to what
you want but you won't find Joy apart
from me because Joy comes from me but
you don't want me so how can you be
filled with joy
yes right so where's the
problem yeah it's soled actually you see
the point so now God God gives you what
you want you don't want me all right I
hand you what you want now you're
miserable and sad and
depressed yes because true joy and love
and peace are found in me I'm the source
of Joy love and peace but you don't want
the source so you can't have the
benefits so you want the benefits but
you don't want me that doesn't work like
that yes
yes right right uh